تخيل انك تستطيع شراء سلاح ناري والاحتفاظ
به فور بلوغك سن الحاديه والعشرين هذا امر
حقيقي ومسموح به للمواطنين في امريكا لكن
لماذا يتم بيع السلاح للمدنيين الدستور
الامريكي يعتبر ان امتلاك المدنيين لاسلحه
ناريه حق من حقوقهم للدفاع عن انفسهم
ويمكن لاي مواطن يبلغ من العمر واحد
وعشرين عاما شراء سلاح ناريه هذا القانون
اعتمد لاول مره عام
1791 ومنذ تلك المده ما زال يثير ضجه
واسعه بين مؤيد ومعارض له نظرا لخطوره
الامر لكن في عام 2022 وقع بايدن على
تشريع يساعد الولايات في حظر حيازه السلاح
على الاشخاص الذين يمكن اعتبارهم يمثلون
خطرا على انفسهم او على الاخرين كما يحضر
التشريع بيع السلاح للمدنين في حوادث عنف
منزلي الاحصائيات الاخيره تشير الى ان
هناك اكثر من 393 مليون سلاح ناري يمت
المدنيين في امريكا في وقت كشفت فيه
تقارير ان حوادث اطلاق النار عام 2022
حصدت ارواح اكثر من 43 الف شخص في
الولايات المتحده واصيب اكثر من 37 الفا
بجروح وبجانب امريكا توجد دول عده تبيع
السلاح لمواطنها كسربيا وكندا وفنلندا
فيما تتخذ دول قوانين اكثر صرامه لبيع
الاسلحه كسنغافوره واليابان وتحضر دول
اخرى بيعها تماما ككوريا الشماليه
واريتريا